mais avant tout édition spéciale nous
sommes à la turballe en loire atlantique
magnifique petit port de pêche breton
pourquoi il vient tout simplement pour
marquer l'anniversaire terrible de la
catastrophe écologique de l'erika
c'était exactement il y a un an le 12
décembre 99 du fioul qui vient polluer
plus de 400 kilomètres de côtes
souvenirs patrick fandio imagine à cet
instant là qu'ils ont encore une chance
qu'ils peuvent encore remorqué au large
la partie arrière plus verica il est 14
heures ce lundi 13 décembre 99
les hommes de l'abeille plantes lille
temps combat inégal
un vent de force 9 des creux de 8 à 10 m
une lutte désespérée pour éviter une
pollution massive mais il n'y a plus
rien à faire
c'est la fin d'une longue agonie
commencé 18 heures plus tôt deux
remorqueurs et les autorités ont été
prévenus trop tard mme erika est resté
trop longtemps
un navire silencieux
à bord du pétrolier ont ce samedi 11
décembre veille du naufrage pour ne
pouvait ignorer la gravité de la
situation
la preuve cette liaison radio à 14h48
entre le capitaine de l' erika et le
ford george le navire anglais qui a
entendu le premier message de détresse
un pont cassé jamais le capitaine de l'
erika nous donnera cette information
capitale au procès tel dans les heures
qui suivent dans ce telex qu'envoyer 30
minutes plus tard il affirme même que la
situation est sous contrôle et annule
son message de détresse
une erreur ou un mensonge karun mathur
qui est rentré chez lui en inde et mises
en examen au cross etel pendant le
naufrage
on a tout enregistré toutes les liaisons
de l'erika pourquoi il n'y a donc pas eu
de surveillance spéciale autour du
pétrolier pourquoi personne n'a pris la
mesure de ce qui se passait pourquoi la
préfecture maritime a été alerte et si
tard
trois officiers sont mises en examen
dont le commissaire de l'ue ici à droite
biella au monténégro c'est dans ce port
que l'erika est censé avoir subi de
grosses réparations des réparations
douteuses dans un chantier naval
spécialisé dans les travaux à moindre
coût grâce à ces travaux
mme erika avait tous ces certificats en
retz tous vivent et paris n'a la société
de classification italienne est
soupçonné d'avoir manqué de vigilance
on sous-estimé l'effet de la corrosion
six de ses employés dont le responsable
technique massimo volta sont mises en
examen également mise en examen le
gestionnaire du pétrolier antonio
pollara et le propriétaire italien
giuseppe savarese la juge dominique de
talancé poursuit son enquête
un an après on est encore très loin d'un
éventuel procès pour que